what kind of relationship do you have
with your father your real father it's
often ambivalent right because there is
an element of him that encouraged you
hopefully because without the
encouragement of your father man the
world is a dismal place very difficult
to be a courageous person unless you
have your father in body and spirit
behind you it's very demoralizing like
it really kills people not to have their
mother they just don't recover from that
but and I think people can recover from
a fragmented father relationship but
it's the next worst thing you know
because if your father rejects you or
doesn't form a relationship with you
it's as if the spirit of civilization
has left you outside the walls as of
littleworth it's very difficult for
people to recover from that so the
father should be an encouraging force
but can be a tyrannical and crushing
force and so that's very that's a very
difficult thing to get right partly
because if you're my son then I should
impose the highest standards of behavior
on you and I should always be judging
what you're doing why should be judging
it with with the aim of making the best
in you come forward but but getting that
balance exactly right is very difficult
and so it's easy to for a father to
swing too much into judgment let's say
and then of course mothers can play this
rule too to swing too far into the
domain of judgment and to be too harsh
and to the degree that the father has
his own pathologies he's going to do
that imperfectly you know he might be
someone who's who's the father who
devours his son because he's jealous of
the new possibility the new potential
that the struggle for for attention and
love from the mother or from the other
children in the family there's all sorts
of things that can go terribly wrong so
that's the father as wise King and
that's another symbol that's been lost I
would say to a massive degree in modern
universities because all we're taught is
to tear that down and to not even notice
that it manifests itself everywhere
especially in the universities which are
like they're as close to an ideal
environment as you could as human beings
have ever been
to create it's as simple as that and if
you can't be grateful for for this
structure of the University with all its
imperfections then then you're
completely blind to this element of the
archetype and that's the opposite of it
that's the Sun that devours the king
that devours his own son that's a tyrant
you know that's like the mother who's
too overprotective it's the male version
of that and the mother that's too
overprotective says I'll never let
anything happen to you it's like well
maybe you actually want to have
something happen to you you know it's a
bit of an all-inclusive statement it's
like no I'm going to make you strong so
any number of things can happen to you
and when you're when you need some care
I'll be there but otherwise like out
into the world with you that's the right
attitude and for the father it's like
get your bloody act together but I'm on
your side it's because not because I
want to destroy you or demean you or
push you down in the dominance hierarchy
but because I want the best in you to
emerge and so all you need standards
it's like what are you doing wasting
your life there's way more than that to
you get your act together and bring it
out and that's a message that people
really want to hear if they have any
sense at all and generally they do want
to hear it so you know I was talking
I've been talking to a lot of people
recently as perhaps you know and what I
was talking to one of the leaders of the
Conservatives this morning and they're
they're asking me about the person was
asking me about well c16 but more
specifically about talking to young
people because the conservative
leadership struggle is going on right
now I've been talking to a bunch of them
and I said well look one of the things
you could do for young people but no
one's doing is to talk to them about
responsibility because everyone talks to
young people about right it's like we
need our rights it's like oh god how
many rights do you need you know really
like you have more privileges than any
people who have ever lived anywhere well
it's so dull to hear that so dull it's
so pathetic and and what would you call
it it's so demeaning that you have to be
protected and have your rights it's like
I said there's a huge marketplace for
responsibility that's what you want to
talk to young people about it's like get
your act together and do something
worthwhile with your life
for the first time my entire adult life
the Conservatives actually have
something to sell young people right
they could sell them responsibility it's
like well why because that's where meat
life has meaning with responsibility the
more responsibility you take on the more
meaning your life has and the the higher
degree of responsibility that you agree
voluntarily to try to bear the richer
your life will be and no one's ever told
that and it's the case you know it's
like you have you have four kids say
well that's plenty of responsibility
you're going to have meaning it's going
to be rough you know because it's
complicated you have a complicated job
and you try to help the careers of the
people around you you try to solve tough
problems and aid suffering and do all of
that it's like its weight its
responsibility but it's there's glory in
it there's real glory in it this deep
meaning in it and and and young people
are starving for that because no one
ever tells them that it's like you're
way more than you think man stand up do
something difficult do something
difficult in heroic right burst out of
your bonds it's like that's a good
message it's a necessary message because
we have to be more than we are because
if we if we are we're not going to
survive